[Music]
when I was a junior in college I was
sexually assaulted the story is very
familiar girl goes out with friends girl
drinks too much girl wakes up somewhere
she doesn't remember going with a
crushing weight on top of her the
predictability of this narrative is
depressing but also oddly heartening
because it means that over the last few
years campus assault has emerged guns
blazing from the category of things we
dare not speak of this is the work of
remarkable young women across the
country who are flipping the script on
campus assault and one of the bravest of
these women is known only by the
pseudonym Emily doe last January Emily
went to a college party at Stanford she
woke up on a gurney covered in dried
blood and pine needles a student named
Brock Turner had sexually assaulted her
behind a dumpster for this act one that
would forever alter the course of his
victims life Brock Turner got six months
in jail
Emily read a statement in court that
demanded accountability from her
attacker and from the legal system her
powerful words went viral Joe Biden very
rightly called her a warrior when I was
assaulted I lived with guilt said I had
been out wasted in a party dress and
fear that I was as inconsequential as I
had been made to feel when I woke up on
the floor ten years later having
publicly disclosed my assault and faced
some of the backlash so many survivors
do I still needed healing I'm gonna go
off script for a moment here to say that
most of the attacks came from right Bart
news where Steve Fannin who's just been
elected as counsel to the
president-elect spent much of his career
working
emilie statement was a gift to survivors
like me one that we will work very hard
to repair
through our honesty and through our
actions Thank You Emily tonight
reading Emily dough's powerful words
from both her original statement to her
assailant and from an essay just
published in Glamour
please welcome actors Gabourey Sidibe
Frieda Pinto and Amber Heard
[Applause]
you don't know me but you've been inside
me and that's why we're here today
January 17 2015 was a quiet Saturday
night at home my dad made some dinner
and I sat at the table with my younger
sister who was visiting for the weekend
I plan to stay at home by myself while
she went to a party with her friends
then I decided I had nothing better to
do so why not there's a dumb party 10
minutes from my house I would go dance
like a fool and embarrass my younger
sister the next thing I remember I woke
up on a gurney in a hallway a deputy
explained to me that I had been
assaulted for now I should go back home
and try my best to move forward with my
life imagine stepping back out into the
world knowing just this information I
was at work scrolling through the news
and my phone and came across an article
I read and learned for the first time
about how I was found unconscious with
my hair disheveled long necklace wrapped
around my neck bra pulled out of my
dress dress pulled off over my shoulders
and pulled up above my waist that I was
butt-naked with my legs spread up I had
been penetrated by a foreign object by
someone I did not recognize in the next
paragraph I read something I will never
forgive I'd read that according to him I
liked it
sometimes I think if I hadn't gone then
none of this would have ever happened
but then I realized it would have
happened just to somebody else
I was not only told that I was assaulted
I was told that because I couldn't
remember I technically could not prove
it unwanted and that distorted me
damaged me almost broke me worst of all
I was warned because he now knows you
don't remember he is going to get to
write the script he can say whatever he
wants and no one can contest
it but in the end his unsupported
statements and his attorneys twisted
logic fooled no one the truth one the
truth spoke for itself
you are guilty you have been convicted
of violating me intentionally forcibly
sexually with malicious intent and all
you can admit to is consuming alcohol do
not talk about the sad way your life was
upturned because alcohol made you do bad
things figure out how to take
responsibility for your own conduct you
took away my mouth my privacy my energy
my time my safety my intimacy my
confidence my own glass until until
today I want to say thank you to
everyone from the intern who made me
oatmeal when I woke up in the hospital
that morning to the deputy who waited
beside me to the detective who listened
to me and never judged me to my
incredible parents who teach me how to
turn pain into strength to my grandma
who's not Chuck chocolate into the
courtroom to give to me to my
unconquerable sister who is the other
half of my heart most importantly thank
you to the two men who saved me who I
have yet to meet
I sleep with two bicycles that I drew
taped above my head to remind myself
there are heroes in the story that we're
looking out for one another to have
known all these people to have felt
their protection and love is something I
will never forget finally two girls
everywhere I am with you on nights when
you feel alone I am with you when people
doubt you or dismiss you I am with you I
fought every day for you now never stop
fighting I believe you I hope that by
speaking today you absorbed a small
to flight a small assurance that we are
getting somewhere and a big big knowing
that you are important unquestionably
you are untouchable you are beautiful
you are to be valued respected
undeniably every minute of every day you
are powerful and nobody can take that
away from you in the very beginning of
it all
one comment lodged harmfully inside me
sad I hope my daughter never ends up
like her
now I am learning to say I hope you end
up like me meaning I hope you end up
like me strong I hope you end up like me
proud of Who I am becoming I hope you
don't end up I hope you keep going and I
hope you grow up knowing that the world
will no longer stand for this victims
are not victims not some fragile
sorrowful aftermath to go
[Applause]
Gabourey Sidibe Frieda Pinto
amber hurt
[Applause]
[Applause]